[Musique]
le pea paris saclay porte une initiative
de plateforme de valorisation des
exploitations agricoles qui s'appelle
donc manger local à paris saclay et qui
a pour objectif en fait de mettre en
lien les agriculteurs les points de
vente et les consommateurs du territoire
que sont à la fois les habitants les
salariés et également les étudiants du
territoire le site
manger local à paris saclay vise
également donc à créer des liens entre
les espaces urbains et les espaces
agricoles du territoire au travers de la
découverte de l'agriculture du plateau
est également des lieux de consommation
de ces produits agricoles cette
plateforme manger local à paris saclay
est notamment financée par le ministère
de la transition écologique au travers
du dispositif territoire à énergie
positive pour la croissance verte
on a la chance sur le plateau de saclay
et autour d'avoir une vingtaine de
fermes qui produisent encore une
diversité de produits locaux on a du
pain des fruits des légumes des produits
laitiers et une partie des terres
agricoles sont protégés par la zone de
protection naturelle agricole et
forestière l'idée de ce site internet
c'est de pouvoir faire profiter à tout
le monde de ces délicieux produits
locaux qu'on a sur le territoire
l'objectif du site c'est de rendre
facile la consommation locale et de vous
donner toutes les infos pratiques pour
accéder aux produits locaux savoir où
ils sont produits dans quelle ferme
qu'est ce qui est produit sur le
territoire et aussi où est ce que vous
pouvez les trouver
donc ce sera simple de trouver les
différents points de vente et les
différents modes d'achats de produits
locaux sur ce site
l'idée du site c'est aussi de mieux
faire comprendre les métiers des
agriculteurs du plateau de saclay et de
vous plonger dans l'univers agricole du
territoire avec notamment des belles
vidéos des belles photos et des
citations des agriculteurs des
explications sur leur travail au
quotidien
bonjour donc bienvenue au garde-manger
est la ferme de romainville des cons
marie jonas on a décidé de diversifier
l'activité de la ferme et d'ouvrir une
boutique ici en rénovant une belle
grange est donc de proposer en fait que
des produits fermiers en circuit court
qui dit sûr que course c'est vraiment du
direct producteur et produits fermés
parce que tout est transformé donc chez
les agriculteurs il ya vraiment pas de
pas d'intermédiaire et l'idée c'était de
proposer déjà nos produits à nous donc
nous on a de la farine de la sphère de
lui les colzas des lentilles vertes et
du miel et de travailler en direct avec
d'autres producteurs pour les fruits et
légumes la viande le fromage la
charcuterie enfin voilà plein de bonnes
choses pour en fait remplir un panier
hebdomadaire
[Musique]